creo que lo divertido para mí es
observar que mis alumnos se emocionan
con las matemáticas porque yo soy una
nerd de las matemáticas al principio mis
alumnos decían las matemáticas son
horrorosas no me gustan nada pero poco a
poco se han ido emocionando cuando
entienden algo
el director y yo escuchamos el mismo día
el mismo noticiero en el que hablaban de
khan academy en un momento del vídeo
mencionaron los ejercicios
ambos reaccionamos igual que ejercicios
y ejercicios de khan y nos dimos cuenta
de que había ejercicios y de que
teníamos que indagar más aquí hay algo
que desde luego podemos utilizar
ya habíamos experimentado con el
aprendizaje en línea con otro programa
que no estaba funcionando y yo había
recurrido a khan academy y me había dado
cuenta de sus ventajas de cuánto podían
aprender los alumnos así que fue
emocionante para ellos aprender con un
formato en línea que realmente
funcionara
lo que nos sorprendió fue la manera en
que caen funciona para ayudar a cambiar
los hábitos de estos chicos antes cuando
no podían resolver algún problema de
tarea se detenía no lo entiendo no lo
voy a hacer pero con khan no pueden
detenerlos porque entonces como avanzan
en el sistema cómo progresan en su
aprendizaje
hay algo en khan que los seduce a
continuar es empiezan a esforzarse en
hacerse responsables de su propio
aprendizaje
a los alumnos de secundaria les faltan
muchas bases definitivamente hay muchas
lagunas como los números negativos
fracciones decimales que gana tercero y
dicen ya he escuchado esto y ya lo sé y
khan academy les dice en realidad no lo
sabes por qué no resolviste bien este
problema y los confronta con su exceso
de confianza y se dan cuenta que
necesitan aprenderlo y al final lo
aprenden por primera vez
examinamos a los alumnos que ingresan
cada año antes de que empiecen los
cursos aplicamos un examen de álgebra
para ver qué tanto saben y
lamentablemente saben muy poco durante
los últimos tres años al promediar la
calificación de los alumnos de nuevo
ingreso la evaluación en álgebra dio 17%
exactamente la misma cifra la última
generación no utilizaba kahn está siendo
utiliza con la misma enseñanza y el
mismo profesor tal como somos realmente
no hemos cambiado kahn está cambiando y
nuestras calificaciones son mucho más
altas el promedio del año pasado fue de
37% el de este año 72%
algunos alumnos mejoraron rápidamente y
se dieron cuenta de que en verdad podían
aprender lo que quisieran siempre y
cuando le dediquen el tiempo necesario
así que tengo chicos que ya están
aprendiendo cálculo y pasar una
geometría inmediatamente porque pensaron
que sería divertido a otros les tomo un
poco más de tiempo darse cuenta de esto
porque aun batallaban con lo básico pero
cada vez más alumnos adquieren mejores
bases y están más contentos de tomar
decisiones acerca de otras oportunidades
de aprendiz
en realidad tenemos los salones
diferentes en mi salón no hay
computadoras tienen un laboratorio de
computación donde dos o tres veces por
semana trabajan exclusivamente con ellas
cuando están conmigo yo explico los
problemas y ellos los resuelven esa es
la diferencia en el salón mis chicos
interesan más les ayudamos más con los
conceptos básicos para la solución de
ecuaciones la factorización de
ecuaciones de segundo grado y la gráfica
ción de problemas antes macián tareas
ahora si las hacen pero son tareas de
can-can está cambiando lo que es
necesario cambiar en estos chicos sus
hábitos de aprendizaje los hace más
responsables cambia ayuda en esa batalla
que no podría ganar por mi cuenta ahora
que están tan involucrados para mí es un
reto mayor ser profesor de matemáticas
porque tengo que encontrar formas de
llevarlos a conocimientos más profundos
resolver problemas más difíciles porque
les interesa y están listos para ello
uno de los grandes cambios que he visto
en nuestros alumnos es cómo se da el
aprendizaje
ellos creían que el profesor pasaba el
conocimiento y ellos se entendían y
aprendían por arte de magia y khan
academy está cambiando eso ahora los
alumnos se dan cuenta que es su
responsabilidad descifrarlo tienen
herramientas que los apoyan pero es su
responsabilidad entenderlo